SO UH YOUR OFFICE IS ALL THE WAY
DOWN AT THE END.
- MM-HMM.
- YOU HAVE YOUR OWN ATTACHED
BATHROOM, BY THE WAY.
OH, UM, HERE'S ONE
OF OUR BEST RESEARCHERS.
DICK?
- HEY.
- AH, HELLO THERE.
[dramatic music]
WHAT'S UP, DUDE?
GLAD TO SEE
THERE'S ANOTHER BROTHER
IN THIS STUFFY PLACE.
- SO, UH, THIS IS GONNA BE
YOUR ASSISTANT, GENEVIEVE.
[dramatic music]
- WHAT IS THIS?
- IT'S THE SHINING, MAN.
ALL BLACK PEOPLE
HAVE THE SHINING.
YOU NEVER SHINED WITH
ANOTHER BLACK PERSON BEFORE?
- NO, I GREW UP
IN A WHITE NEIGHBORHOOD
AND THEN WENT TO DARTMOUTH.
I'VE MET
OTHER BLACK PEOPLE BEFORE,
BUT NOT LIKE THIS.
- YOU GOTTA GET SHINED AT
BY ANOTHER BLACK PERSON FIRST,
AND THEN YOU GET IT.
IT'S KINDA LIKE FACEBOOK.
[dramatic music]
- WHAT UP, DUDES?
- SO EVERY BLACK PERSON
HAS THIS?
IS KOBE LISTENING?
- [voice of Kobe Bryant]
YO, WHAT UP?
- WOW! DENZEL WASHINGTON?
- [voice of Denzel Washington]
I'M HERE, I'M PRESENT,
AND I WILL ALWAYS
BE AROUND.
- LIL JON?
- [voice of Lil Jon]
YEAH!
- [voice of Barack Obama]
EXCUSE ME, LIL JON.
WELCOME, RAY.
I'M GLAD TO HAVE YOU
ON BOARD.
- OH, [bleep]!
WHAT'S UP, BARACK OBAMA?
AHEM!
[chuckles]
WOULDN'T THAT BE SOMETHING
IF BARACK OBAMA JUST SHOWED UP?
- YOUR START-UP PAPERWORK'S
RIGHT OVER HERE.
[dramatic music]
- MAN, YOU GOTTA BE
MORE CAREFUL.
LEARN TO USE THE SHINING.
TUNE IN AND OUT OF IT.
OTHERWISE,
YOU WON'T BE ABLE
TO SORT OUT WHO'S TALKING.
- AND I'M SICK OF THESE
GODDAMN SNAKES...
- JUST GIVE ME
THE BASKETBALL!
- ON THIS GODDAMN PLANE!
- HERE, YO, COCO, WHAT
YOU WANT TO DRINK, GIRL?
- LEO, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- DRINK SOME COLT 45
MALT LIQUOR.
[overlapping voices]
- WOMEN DIG CHOCOLATE!
- IS EVERYTHING OKAY?
[dramatic music]
- RAY!
LISTEN FOR MORGAN.
MORGAN FREEMAN.
HE WILL GUIDE YOU.
- [voice of Morgan Freeman]
LISTEN TO MY VOICE, RAY.
NOW, JUST STAY CALM
AND FOCUS ON THAT WHITE MAN.
- [exhales]
EVERYTHING'S
GOING TO BE OKAY.
- ONCE YOU FINISH UP
THIS PAPERWORK,
BRING IT TO JENNIFER
IN MY OFFICE.
- [voice of Morgan Freeman]
NOW, PICK UP THAT LETTER OPENER,
AND KILL THAT WHITE MAN.